[Music]
can I just say and I don't mean to be
bold that your bottom is the best bottom
I've ever seen in my life
I'm trying to cover that up why would
you and I would just walk up and down
thank you about being hurt the Kingsmen
to premier and London lecture square you
know it's it's a big deal events you
know this movie you know it's kind of
you know I think beloved here right and
I've been a big fan of these kind of
movies I was in a Bond movie and that
royal premiere is one of my fondest
memories of my career so to be back here
in London for another premiere the
tically a special was really excited
let's get started
[Music]
I think everybody's loved it so far I
haven't met one person that saw it
unless they weren't being honest with me
I've been seen one person that said that
they just didn't love it that it was a
good fun ride and lastly if you have a
statesman named agent white what is your
drink of choice I'm gonna be agent
ginger ale I like being the mixer
because the mixer goes with everything
and I like that
[Music]